Although she's digitally rendered to look
alien, Proxima Midnight's voice and facial
structure are sure to make you ask yourself:
"Where do I know her from?"
Carrie Coon's convincingly intimidating motion-capture
performance in Infinity War is yet another
impressive addition to her acting résumé.
Talk about a successful debut: For her very
first feature film appearance, Coon starred
alongside Ben Affleck in Gone Girl, the adaptation
of Gillian Flynn's twisted novel of the same
name.
Coon starred as Margo Dunne, twin sister of
Affleck's leading man, Nick Dunne.
She got the part by sending in an audition
tape, and she must've really knocked it out
of the park in order to get cast the old-fashioned
way.
Coon really showcased the full range of her
acting chops, and it definitely had an effect
on the film's success.
Gone Girl was a massive box office hit, bringing
in nearly $370 million worldwide.
If the first movie you ever act in goes on
to become one of the top 20 highest-grossing
films of the year, you must be doing something
right.
HBO's psychological mystery drama The Leftovers
focused on the lives of several people who
remained on Earth after two percent of the
entire global population vanished in a rapture-like
event.
The series ran for three seasons and 28 episodes
from 2014 to 2017.
Coon portrayed Nora Durst, a grieving widower
who lost both her husband and her children
in the event.
She still views her work on the show with
great regard.
In an interview with The Hollywood Reporter,
she raved about how it affected her career,
declaring:
"I rarely get recognized and whenever I do,
it has to do with The Leftovers because it
came into someone's life at a particularly
important time for them if they were dealing
with grief or loss or whatever tragedy and
they just caught it."
In the spring of 2017, Coon's acting career
really caught fire.
While simultaneously shooting The Leftovers,
she also joined the cast of FX's smash hit
series Fargo for its third season.
A black comedy wrapped up in a crime anthology,
the show is based on the Coen brothers' 1996
film of the same name.
Coon starred as Gloria Burgle, the recently
divorced chief of police in snowy Eden Valley,
Minnesota.
"Those are facts, and you at the heart of
the morass.
What else am I supposed to see?"
Despite starring alongside such A-list actors
as Ewan McGregor and Mary Elizabeth Winstead,
Coon commanded viewers' attention, even earning
an Emmy nomination for Lead Actress in a Limited
Series or TV Movie.
In an interview with Entertainment Weekly,
she opened up a bit about the "spring of Carrie
Coon," saying,
"Oh gosh, this year, this extraordinary year…
It's funny, I feel like I'm still processing
this year that I've had … I feel I’ve
been working nonstop for years now, and I
haven’t had time to take a breath."
It's generally considered a great honor to
work on a Steven Spielberg film, and Carrie
Coon is one of the lucky talents who can flaunt
that achievement on her IMDb page.
In The Post, she portrayed journalist Meg
Greenfield, a proud member of the Washington
Post team responsible for publishing the Pentagon
Papers in 1971.
The film, which also starred Tom Hanks and
Meryl Streep, brought in nearly $180 million
at the worldwide box office and nabbed two
Oscar nominations.
Although her role was fairly minor, Coon's
time on set with an acclaimed director and
two of the biggest names in Hollywood history
is not an experience she will soon forget.
She told Parade,
"The thing that I loved about working with
Meryl, Tom and Steven is that they all so
clearly still love what they're doing.
They've been making films for decades and
it's still magical for them, still moving
for them, and important."
Steve McQueen's Widows featured an all-star
cast led by Viola Davis, Michelle Rodriguez,
Elizabeth Debicki, and Liam Neeson.
And although her role was small, you can't
forget to include Carrie Coon on that list.
The 2018 film follows four women forced to
embark on a heist after their gangster husbands
are killed.
Coon plays Amanda, one of the widows who decides
not to partake in the plan.
Although it garnered a decent amount of buzz
prior to its release, it ultimately didn't
fare too well at the box office, only earning
$76 million worldwide.
In an interview with Observer, Coon dished
about her favorite parts of working on Widows,
which was shot in her hometown of Chicago.
She appreciated McQueen bringing his unique
point of view to a genre film, working alongside
greats such as Davis and Neeson, and getting
to sleep in her own bed for a change.
In the acting world, you can't put a price
tag on working close to home.
In the first season of USA's dark mystery
thriller The Sinner, Jessica Biel shined as
a woman coming to grips with the demons of
her past.
For Season 2, the showrunners needed to find
a new leading lady to fill Biel's shoes.
Although she wasn't their first choice, the
role of commune leader Vera Walker eventually
went to Coon.
"She sneaks into your room at night and sits
on your chest.
Have you ever been visited by her?"
The really interesting part of this story
is that Coon hadn't even intended to be on
the show at all.
It was actually her husband, Pulitzer-Prize
winning playwright Tracy Letts, who received
the casting call for the role of Jack Novack.
Since Coon had just delivered their first
child, she was looking forward to taking some
time off from acting.
But when the role of Vera was reopened, they
offered it to Coon, and the rest is history.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.